- [Instructor] Let's say we have a beaker
of distilled water at 25 degrees Celsius.
And to the beaker, we
add some barium sulfate.
Barium sulfate is a white solid.
A small amount of the barium sulfate
dissolves in the water and
forms Ba2+ ions in solution
and sulfate ions in solution.
So let me draw those in on our diagrams.
So we're gonna form some Ba2+ ions
and some sulfate anions.
But most of the barium
sulfate remains undissolved
and so we'll draw that
here sitting on the bottom
of the beaker.
So barium sulfate can
dissolve to form Ba2+ ions
and sulfate anions in solution.
And it's possible for the Ba2+ ion
to combine with the sulfate
anion to form a precipitate,
of barium sulfate.
When the rate of dissolution
is equal to the rate of
precipitation, the
system is at equilibrium.
These types of equilibria are referred
to as solubility equilibria.
And when the system is at equilibrium,
the concentrations of Ba2+
ions and sulfate anions
solution are constant.
And the amount of solid is constant too.
And this forms a saturated solution.
The balanced equation
shows the dissolution
of a salt barium sulfate.
And from the balanced equation,
we can write an equilibrium
constant expression.
So we would write the
equilibrium constant K
is equal to the concentration of Ba2+
and since there's a coefficient of one
in the balanced equation,
it'd be the concentration
raised to the first power
times the concentration of sulfate
also raised to the first power.
And since pure solids are left
out of equilibrium constant
expressions, we would not
include the solid barium sulfate.
For solubility equilibria,
we would write Ksp where sp
stands for solubility product.
The solubility product constant
Ksp has only one value for a
given salt at a specific temperature.
That temperature is
usually 25 degrees Celsius.
And Ksp indicates how much
of that salt will dissolve.
For example, at 25 degrees Celsius,
the Ksp value for barium sulfate
is 1.1 times 10 to the negative 10th.
When the Ksp value is much less than one,
that indicates the salt
is not very soluble.
So barium sulfate is not a soluble salt.
If the Ksp value is greater than one,
like it is for something
like sodium chloride,
that indicates a soluble salt
that dissolves easily in water.
The solubility of a substance
refers to the amount of solid
that dissolves to form
a saturated solution.
Usually the units for solubility
are in grams per liter.
Molar solubility refers to the
number of moles of the solid
that dissolve to form one litter
of the saturated solution.
And therefore the units
would be moles per one liter
or you could just write M.
Ksp values can be used to
predict the relative solubilities
of salts that produce the same
number of ions in solution.
For example, silver
chloride, silver bromide,
and silver iodide all
produce two ions in solution.
Let's look at the dissolution
equation for silver chloride
to see why this is true.
Solid silver chloride
turns into Ag+ and Cl-.
So that's one Ag+ ion and
one Cl- ion for a total
of two ions in solution.
And we could write out similar
equations for silver bromide
and silver iodide, so they all
produce two ions in solution.
However, a salt like Lead(II)chloride
produces three ions in solution.
So Lead(II)chloride
would give one Pb2+ ion
and two chloride anions in solution.
One plus two is three ions.
Since Lead(II)chloride produces
three ions in solution,
we can determine its solubility
relative to the other
three by comparing Ksp values.
Here are the Ksp values
for the three salts
at 25 degrees Celsius.
For silver chloride, it's 1.8
times 10 to the negative 10th,
for silver bromide, it's 5.0
times 10 to the negative 13th.
And for silver iodide, it's 8.3 times 10
to the negative 17th.
When comparing salts that
produce the same number of ions,
the higher the value of Ksp,
the higher the solubility of the salt.
And since silver chloride has
the highest Ksp value of these
three, silver chloride is
the most soluble salts.
For some insight into why this is true,
let's look at the Ksp
expression for silver chloride,
which we can get from
the balanced equation.
The higher the value for Ksp,
the higher the concentration
of these ions at equilibrium,
which means that more of the
solid must have dissolved.
Therefore, silver chloride
has the highest solubility
out of these three salts.
Let's say we have some solid
calcium fluoride that we add to
pure water at 25 degrees Celsius.
Eventually equilibrium is
reached and the equilibrium
concentration of Ca2+ ions is measured
to be 2.1 times 10 to the negative 4th M.
Our goal is to calculate
the Ksp for calcium fluoride
at 25 degrees Celsius.
The first step is to write out the
dissolution equation for calcium fluoride.
So we would write CaF2 solid,
and we know that calcium forms
a 2+ cation, so we would
write Ca2+ in aqueous solution
and to balance everything
we'd need two fluoride anions.
So 2F- also in aqueous solution.
The next step is to use
the balanced equation
to write the Ksp expression.
So Ksp is equal to, there's
a one as a coefficient
in front of Ca2+ so it'd
be the concentration
of Ca2+ raise to the first power,
times the concentration of fluoride anion
and since there's a two as a coefficient,
this is the concentration
of fluoride anion squared.
For a Ksp expression, these
are equilibrium concentrations,
and we already know the
concentration of Ca2+
at equilibrium is 2.1 times
10 to the negative 4th.
So that can be plugged in for the
equilibrium concentration of Ca2+.
So here's our expression with 2.1 times 10
to the negative 4th plugged in,
and next we need to
plug in the equilibrium
concentration of fluoride anion.
We're looking at the disillusion equation,
the mole ratio of Ca2+
to fluoride anion is 1:2.
Therefore, at equilibrium,
there's twice as many
fluoride ions in solution
as there are Ca2+ ions.
Therefore the equilibrium
concentration of the fluoride
anion would just be twice
this concentration for Ca2+.
So the equilibrium
concentration of fluoride anion
must be 4.2 times 10
to the negative 4th M.
And when you do the math, you get that Ksp
for calcium fluoride is
equal to 3.7 times 10
to the negative 11th
at 25 degrees Celsius.
Ksp values can be difficult to measure
and therefore different sources
often give different values
for Ksp at the same temperature.
For example, for calcium
fluoride at 25 degrees Celsius,
one source had Ksp equal to 3.5 times 10
to the negative 11th.
Another one had 3.9 times
10 to the negative 11th.
Since we got 3.7 times
10 to the negative 11th,
this sounds like a pretty good
calculation for the numbers
that we used for our problem.
Finally, let's think
about the molar solubility
of calcium fluoride.
So how many moles of our
salt dissolve to form
one litter of our saturated solution?
Well, the mole ratio of Ca2+ ions
to calcium fluoride is 1:1.
Therefore, the concentration
of Ca2+ ions in solution 2.1
times 10 to the negative 4th M,
that number must also
be the molar solubility
of calcium fluoride.
Therefore, for this problem,
we could say that we use the
molar solubility of calcium
fluoride to calculate
the Ksp value for calcium fluoride.